you're watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with economist
carol malone and the political editor of
the liverpool echo liam thorpe they'll
be with us from now until just before
midnight so let's see what's on some of
those front pages for you now
responding to prince andrew losing his
military status royal patronages and hrh
title the metro splash is thrown out
the sun has the same headline pointing
out that the duke of york is now a
private citizen
the telegraph describes him as having
been frozen out by his mother the queen
the duke of york's change in status is
also the lead story for the guardian
the times believes he will feel
humiliated
and the express suggests the decision
was taken for the sake of the monarchy
meanwhile the preston journal focuses on
tory infighting after senior westminster
conservatives disparaged the party's
scottish leader douglas ross for
insisting the prime minister should
resign having attended a party in the
downing street garden during lockdown
and the financial times reports that
talks between the us and russia
over ukraine remain unresolved
and you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers as they come in by
scanning the qr code on your screen
right now
and we're joined tonight by carol malone
and liam thorpe welcome to you both good
evening um let's start with the
front page of the metro and just two
words everybody will know what uh this
headline alludes to thrown out
carol
yeah this is um when andrews and court
case was thrown out this week when it
was it was deemed that he would have to
go to court and the queen and and the
monarchy had to take action and today
they did and it was pretty decisive
action he's been stripped um of his
honorary honorary and military roles
he won't lose the title of hras but he's
not going to be allowed to use it which
is just as much this is a a massive
humiliation for him it's
in recent years andrew hasn't done much
with his life
hasn't had much going on in his life
apart from this and to take away his
titles now is going to be devastating
for him one wonders what he's going to
do with the rest of his life but frankly
i don't really care that much about him
what i'm kind of
incredulous about that this has happened
in the year of the queen's platinum
jubilee this should have been per year
this should have been the year that she
celebrated joyously 70 years on the
throne it's nine months after her
husband's death this should have been a
year to celebrate her and now we're
going to be distracted by this and it's
i you know this i can't imagine how hard
this must have been for the queen can't
come begin to imagine i don't suppose
she took the decision alone in fact i
suspect it was probably prince charles
who took the final decision because he
he's going to be the next person to take
over and he it's his job to protect the
monarchy as it is the queens
if there's any conflict for the queen
tonight it's that you know social media
everyone is saying that it was the right
decision how proud they are of her how
yet again
this this this grand lady has put duty
and the monarchy above
personal self above her family even
above her favorite son and that andy was
always being rumored to be her son this
must have been unutterably hard for her
and liam from what we read uh senior
members of the royal family have uh
deliberated over this to arrive at this
decision so tonight uh prince andrew is
a private citizen and he will go forth
and fight this civil case as as such
like like anyone else would have to he
was in that position you know he can't
hide behind
those titles or or the family anymore
he's got to to face up to those very
very serious allegations and it looks
like that's going to be heard in court
as carol says you know this uh this um
announcement came just just a day after
that court in new york and made that
decision that the case can can go ahead
and that's not a coincidence it's swift
and and pretty brutal and and uh um
action from the queen and ana's car says
completely humiliating for him and as
you say i think there was discussions
between prince charles and possibly
prince william yesterday and then as we
understand it a
quite brief curt 45-minute chat between
the queen and prince andrew today where
that was clear and you know the
statement says it's been done in
agreement i think we all know that's not
true there's no way he would have wanted
to agree to this but it had to be done
and now he's a private citizen
like anyone else faced with allegations
has to go and and face justice
yes and the the stripping of the uh
military roles uh is something as you
suggest will be particularly galling to
him but we know that there was some
pressure from within the military that
this should be the case carol
oh yeah i mean i think they're i think
it's it's the grenadiers i think they're
they're delighted to be shot at him they
don't want to be tarnished with what's
happening to him you know and it's it is
it's incredible you know it's it's hard
to see what's going to happen here
because
if he settles that's kind of if he
settles and the rumors are that that if
he does it he'd be looking at 10 million
quid to virginia roberts referee as we
now know her um a lot of money he's
actually selling his chalet in
switzerland to try and pay for that but
if he settles that's a kind of admission
of guilt i guess um
victoria roberts is saying currently she
doesn't want to settle that
the rumors are that she wants her today
in court but i can't see her not
settling 99 out of 100 cases in civil
courts in the u.s are settled and i
think what all this rhetoric is about
upping the
auntie it's about getting the biggest
settlement that she possibly can um but
you know the problem with settling is
going to be that a lot of
other girls
might come forward girls who they say
were trafficked by jeffrey epstein and
who may andu may have been involved with
so this kind of whatever happens here
whether he goes to border whether he
settles it's not going to be over
anytime soon no he says life has changed
forever hasn't it liam
yeah as carl says this is uh you know
it's
apart from uh trying to defend himself i
guess it's hard to know what he does
it's a completely different life to the
one that he has led
the interesting thing i think is you
know he's repeatedly uh denied these
allegations and a lot of people have
said well if you are you know being
continually levied with these
allegations wouldn't you want to go and
and clear your name and defend yourself
but his legal team have done everything
they possibly can to avoid that day in
court but it hasn't been enough and it
looks like that's either gonna happen or
as carol says there'll be a settlement
but it's it's uh it's definitely not
going his way i just want to get to the
the telegraph to to fit this in before
the break carol um and uh this is news
of two more
downing street parties
yeah breaking story tonight by a
political correspondent on the telegraph
called tony diver it's saying that
number hell
number 10 held two boozy parties the
night before the queen mourned for
prince philip on her own at the time the
rules stated that you couldn't socialize
indoors except with your household or in
a support bubble um
and so and here we go again it's
incredible you know boris was just
things were settling um i'm not saying
that he was out of the out of the the
woods because he certainly isn't and
won't be but i mean this here is yet
another thing to it i don't know whether
this is going to be the killer blow we
don't know whether he was there we knew
there were two parties where staff drank
and danced until the early hours one was
for it was a leaving party um of of one
of his comms bosses a guy called james
slack who had been there for
who had been in the job for two previous
prime ministers and one was for one of
boris's personal photographers uh but
these these parties were happening while
prince philip was lying in the church in
winter castle and you know no one will
forget the picture of the queen the next
day sitting alone in church socially
distanced from her entire family
and and here we have more parties and
down the street i mean this is
catastrophic for the government it's
i can't even believe the telegraph
haven't lead on it actually it's kind of
it's halfway down the page yeah this is
catastrophic it is on the front page
carol we're going to have to stop
there just because of time because we
want to go to a break but just to
reiterate on the stories to do with that
prince andrew we must absolutely
reiterate that he strenuously denies all
allegations